I think the whole conversation
about Mother's Day being for moms in the trenches
has kind of gotten lost in the sauce
here on TikTok.
Made a lot of videos about this over the years.
So I am definitely of the
the mom with the young kids
to do whatever the fuck she wants on Mother's Day.
But here's the thing.
If you, with a young child, wanna spend your Mother's Day with your mom,
with your grandma,
with other moms,
you should do whatever you want to do.
The point is that if a mom who has young kids
wants to spend the day reading a book on the beach by herself
and getting a moment of peace,
that she should be able to do that without obligation or guilt.
A lot of what's being lost in this conversation
is that the mom with the young kids
probably doesn't have a good boundary set with her mother
or her grandmother
or her mother in law.
She routinely takes a back seat in her wants and needs.
And she should be allowed to have one day
where her wants and needs are considered,
because although she's of course
always gonna be her mother's daughter,
she should be able to spend that day however she wants
because she's not less of a mother than her own mother.
She could probably use the break from packing the kids up
and taking a back seat.